I'd love to talk a little bit about the
new book uh the love prescription seven
days to more intimacy connection and joy
I've started reading that on my Kindle
and I've got the physical copy arriving
in the next in the next couple of days
um but it's interesting because one of
the one of the claims in the book or at
least in the in the blurb is that there
is a formula for a good relationship and
if you just I almost the vibe that I got
was that hey if you follow the formula
and just do these seven things across
these seven days or however however long
it takes you will just almost magically
improve the quality of your relationship
uh so I wonder if you can just kind of
Riff on that a little bit like what is
this formula for love thank you
sure so one of the things is being nice
to one another
so you know
giving a part of compliments uh you know
uh catching a partner doing something
right and and communicating that
communicating respect and affection and
words letting your partner know how
attractive they are to you and how
irresistible they seem at times you know
those that kind of positivity is very
very critical another one is
turning toward it turns out to be a very
powerful thing in a relationship so you
know in our apartment lab we saw 130
newlywed couples and followed them for
six years
we discovered that a lot of time when
they're just kind of hanging out in this
apartment lab one person will try to get
the other person's attention or share
something humorous or you know some
interesting story that they've heard or
are reading about and then they try to
connect they make a bid for connection
and then the cameras in the lab always
swung to the other person to see the
response and there were one of three
responses turning toward which was you
know really acknowledging the connection
you know one person might say Oh What a
Beautiful boat that is you know going by
and if the other person said yeah huh
that was turning toward because they
didn't respond at all that was turning
away or if they responded irritably
would you be quiet I'm trying to read
that was turning against
so when we followed couples the the 17
couples who divorced one another after
uh six years after the wedding uh when
we looked back six years earlier they
had turned toward these bids only 33
percent of the time
whereas the couples who are still
together six years earlier had turned
toward the bids 86 percent of the time
you know huge difference
and we also discovered that turning
toward is like an emotional bank account
that you build when you really connect
with your partner when your partner
wants to connect with you then
during conflict
you have more of a sense of humor about
yourself and about one another you can
laugh together and you can be
affectionate even when you disagreeing
and it reduces physiological arousal so
turning toward is another one that's
very very powerful and when people
become aware of that as a tool of
connecting then the relationship
improves quite dramatically right so in
this book what we're doing is each day
we're giving couples little thing to do
little 10-minute thing to do every
single day like one day we'll be giving
compliments you know really expressing
fondness and admiration a second day
will be look for what your partner is
doing right
and not just wrong right and point it
out and say thank you to your partner
you know third is listening you know
talking about your needs with one
another what do you need and we
emphasize you should bring up your needs
as a positive need rather than a
negative need and what that means is
that you ask for what you do want
not what you don't like or you present
don't bring that up because that's going
to sound like criticism instead flip it
on its head and say I would love it if
you clean the dishes three times a week
that would be such a big help to me
that's a positive me so uh people
present you know on I forget which day
they talk about one need they have with
their partner that can allow their
partner to shine for them
it's not a criticism it's the opposite
right another one is honoring each
other's dreams so talk about what maybe
deeply hell dream you have for something
you want to do something you want to
experience something you want to feel
whatever it is
share that with your partner and really
listen to what your partner says about
that question too
so you know there what we hope to see if
people practice this every day for seven
days is that from before they started it
to the end of the week they'll see a
little bit of change maybe little
something feels different and they can
talk about which one of those little
prescriptions really made a difference
for them
now it doesn't mean everything gets
fixed in seven days and then you can go
back to being whoever you were before no
it's instead that you're learning how to
do something a little different that
deepens the Friendship deepens emotional
intimacy which of course opens up to you
know what you know more sexual intimacy
and helps you when you have to talk
about conflict continue those practices
especially the ones you found the best
for you and your partner
and you'll see over time you know the
relationship is doing this over time big
change
hey friends thank you so much for
watching if you enjoyed this clip then
click here for the full unedited episode
and if you like that then do please
consider subscribing to the channel it
means a lot thank you so much and have a
great day bye